how does default aggressive
apply to jiu-jitsu
or does it apply to jiu-jitsu well
good question now
well first of all it doesn't apply
during training okay it but it
completely applies
during competition and obviously it
applies in the streets
so so what i mean by that is
in training it's okay to get in bad
positions it's okay
to let things happen it's okay to let
somebody grab that collar or grab that
sleeve or get across
it's okay i mean those it's okay to put
yourself at risk in competitions that's
okay
matter of fact it's it's encouraged in a
lot of ways in training yeah in training
it's encouraged
in training but in competition
you can't do that you can you cannot do
that in the street
you definitely cannot do that in fact in
the street
you've got to proactively and
aggressively first of all avoid the bad
situation but if they come then you've
got to handle those situations with
aggression
and speed and violence of action that's
what you got to do
so competition is kind of the same way
in competition if you give a guy an
inch if you give a guy a grip if you
give a guy a position
they will not they will not let go of it
it's not happening
they they will they will hang on to that
thing
like like with the ghee in competition
somebody gets a grip on some part of
your ghee
they they white knuckle that thing
especially especially in the lower belts
but it's the higher belts too man it's
every belt because that
ghee that grip can be the difference
between winning and losing
period yep so
you you gotta you gotta aggressively
avoid that you gotta be aggressive with
your positions now
in training again you let it happen but
here's something that can happen in
training sometimes you get guys
that get used to training and they go
into competition they get overrun
they get overwhelmed and overrun because
they they thought man i'll just oh the
guy grabs my collar
hey jocko grabs my collar all every time
we roll right
and they don't realize that when this
guy grabs your collar he's going to
attack
yeah and so what you have to do and the
other thing is
in in a competition there's a time limit
because there is
there is kind of a a uh
there's such a thing sort of as a
counter puncher in jiu jitsu
right someone that and i'm kind of like
that yeah right like i don't
i don't usually force a move to happen
usually i'm gonna let you make your own
mistakes i'm gonna let my opponent
make a bad move then i'm gonna
capitalize on it because there's a lot
less work for me i mean it's
it's it's a lot less work when your
opponent gives you
gives you the submission or gives you
the transition or gives you the sweep
than trying to make it happen
but again in competition
it doesn't really work because they're
not going to give they're not going to
take any risk
they're not going to take any risk and
there's probably not going to be any
openings now again another piece isn't
it long match
maybe my you know maybe i'm just trying
to tire somebody out yeah now in the gym
i have an unlimited time to do that i
can tire somebody out for 20 minutes
just trying to let them
pass my guard and they're trying to pass
my guard the whole time i'm getting them
tired of getting him tired getting him
tired finally they expose himself boom i
put the choke on
good i win that took 20 minutes this
happens
on a daily basis yeah in a competition i
just lost
because it was a 10 minute match and the
other guy was on top for 10 minutes
trying to pass and he got the advantage
and he wins
so you can't that can't be your strategy
if there's no time limit it's the same
thing in war right in war
you can have a strategy of i'm just
gonna wear the other person now i mean
the the vietnamese did it to america
right they just kind of wore us out
look at what the russian strategy of
that they used against napoleon they
used against the nazis oh you want to
come at us cool we're just going to back
up a little bit at a time
back up a little bit of time back up a
little bit time here comes the winter
and and now you're gonna freeze to death
and we're gonna surround you and you're
gonna kill you
but that's the same type of strategy it
doesn't work if you
if you have a limited amount of time to
win yeah you have to have
if you if you have a limited amount of
time which most cases you do you have to
have a default aggressive attitude
and make things happen the way you want
them to happen not the way your opponent
wants to happen
have them happen not the way your enemy
wants them to happen
and it's the same thing obviously in
business and in life
the good things the good positions the
good
details the good promotions the rewards
they're not gonna come and knock on your
door you gotta go out
and you gotta take them you gotta make
them happen
on the mat in business and in life
so get default aggressive that's my
recommendation
yeah it's weird and jiu-jitsu is so
ambiguous
as far as like a like an art and there's
like this big spectrum and there's all
these
exceptions you know how you say the
counter puncher
in jiu jitsu where like some guys even
like you can be a counter puncher in jiu
jitsu and still
be like aggressive but so your first
move won't be like
okay if you're going for a sweep your
first move won't be the sweep
yeah you'll go okay i'm going to do this
other thing i know his reaction is going
to open him up for the sweep
well for sure for sure that's that's
that's cover and move actually
it's cover move it's flanking it's it's
flanking
yeah because you know i start attacking
your neck
and you pull your hand up to defend it
boom that took your base away i'm
sweeping you right right boom that's
that's what it was it was a cover move
covering my actual attack with my other
move
yeah or you can call it a flank because
you think i'm going to come at the front
but then i'm flanking you from the side
with the sweep
yeah when you put all your troops on the
front you know the front yeah
it's almost like that's almost like a
philosophical
question where you can answer it
as it applies to something specific so
like for example like default aggressive
in jiu jitsu meaning
my default aggressive way of approaching
it will give me advantage in this way
where i'm going to impose my game
whether that's the counter punching game
whether it's the where am out for a
while game whether it's
you know over running with my
conditioning game whatever that game is
i'm gonna aggressively put it on him
before he puts it on me def
like right from the time the guy says go
or you know
when it goes down the street whenever
even in training whatever you're
training like that if you want
so that'll keep him in the defensive
where he can't get his game going on you
you know he's defending your game the
whole time yeah
you definitely definitely want to impose
your will you say that all the time with
ufc fighters
you want the ufc fighter that imposes
his will on the other fighters is going
to win
yeah they're going to win and it's the
same thing with war you impose your will
on the enemy
that's what you do you impose your will
on the enemy and you will break them
yeah man that's why you see guys like in
ufc they'll they'll run to the middle of
the ring you know
because they're like controlling their
ring or like a bj pen would all be
if he's coaching somebody he'll be like
be first be first be first no it's like
you put him so the guy got to defend the
whole time
it's when you when you're going against
a striker that has that attitude
and is being first it's absolutely not
fun it's not fun
they're hitting you and you're not
you're just defending the whole time
yeah and it's hard to turn it around
yeah
yeah and you can tell like when you roll
against a guy and we talk about this
before when you roll against a guy and
even if he's not
like his game isn't aggressive but
right when you lock up with him you can
tell he's just like just in the
correct position you're like dang i
can't get like a good like and when you
you're like okay i'm gonna get in my
position and he just adjusts like
immediately yeah you're in trouble yeah
you're like oh dang that's that's in a
way even though that might be like kind
of like a passive game sometimes
it's like just his game being put on you
position wise in this case
yeah is that default as opposed to like
you know like you know sometimes like in
training you're training with me you'll
be like okay i'm gonna it's essentially
letting someone get in
into a good position on you so you're
training your
defense or whatever that's different
that's like that's not
default aggressive no you're talking
about i'm really good from the half
guard
yeah so i let you get past my full guard
to the half guard and now you're in my
world
like something like that yeah that would
be
i guess would that be well it's like
stilts
stilts has his weird game because he's
tall and lanky yeah
and and flexible and so he does
things like he'll stick his foot in a
place where any normal
situation in jiu jitsu you'd grab his
foot all day long yeah
that's what he wants you to do yeah and
i was just telling him the other day i
said all these little things that you
want me to do i'm not doing any of them
yeah
and you just stop doing them and so the
way he
imposes his will is by giving up these
bait he just throws bait out there all
day long and he wants you to get you
into these positions that he's good at
yeah and so you can't take the bait you
can't take the bait and sometimes the
bait is ripe looking
yeah it's like ripe for the harvest yeah
and it's everywhere and it's everywhere
yeah and so you gotta just
say no i'm gonna stick to the game plan
here yeah i'm gonna impose my will which
is i'm not gonna grab the bait yeah and
that's so crazy because
like i said kind of philosophically that
is a default aggressive thing when all
you're throwing out is
absolutely so instead of imposing my
game i'm like kind of lured by this bait
even if you know the bait is there
you're on your heels because you're
watching out for the trap
well this is just to kind of i think
down the same vein that you're talking
about
i i talk about i talk about safety like
i'll talk to
companies about safety you know
industrial companies or construction
companies
manufacturing companies that have you
know can have people get killed
if they're not careful and so i talk
about being aggressive
and you know it's okay well then jocko
how does default aggressive gonna keep
us safe because if i got guys that are
out in a construction site being super
aggressive all day guess what they're
going to take risks that they shouldn't
i say absolutely wrong because guess
what you're going to get aggressive with
you're going to aggressively implement
your safety procedures
you're going to aggressively like hey
you know what i see a guy walking around
the job site without a helmet we're all
over him
hey jackass put your helmet on get over
here i'm writing you
whatever you're gonna do all right right
oh i see a guy without a seatbelt hey
you're not allowed to be on the site
without a without a a seatbelt on
get over here you gotta you know we're
docking your pay you're gonna get
aggressive
in the implementation of your safety
procedures and yes
that will make you safer yeah so it's
yeah i guess
um when you hear the word aggressive
automatically yeah i'll give you another
physical example
another physical example is okay we're
in a defensive perimeter
i don't have enough men to move or i've
got wounded guys
i am going to aggressively set security
right i'm going to put a big machine gun
over here i'm going to get that high
ground over there
so you can do things aggressively even
though by their nature they
might not seem aggressive yeah at first
yeah i think that's what you're trying
to say
yeah yeah fully so it's it it it's
almost like it's deeper it's deeper than
just like physically just jumping in
you know it's more like the the idea of
whatever's going on
here's another one i am going to
aggressively
ignore you no i'm going to aggressively
counsel you and mentor you now
the worst thing i could do is go echo
you better listen to me that's the worst
thing i could do
but to be aggressive in doing that what
am i going to do
i'm going to set really good goals i'm
going to flank you i'm going to
get into your mind i'm being aggressive
but it's not an external aggression
it's an internal aggression that only i
know is happening you're going to know
what's happening
in a year when you've all sudden
improved and you've been successful
and you go dang man jocko's really
helped me out with some stuff i didn't
really realize that was going on but he
did
i was aggressively doing it but you
would have never called it aggressive
from an external viewpoint yeah so it's
as opposed to let's say like some sort
of a laid-back approach
right like if you yeah if you have a
laid-back approach to security if you
have a laid-back approach to mentorship
or a laid-back approach to safety yes
none of those things are good
exactly that's why we have a default
aggressive attitude about things there
you go
clarify i did after it
i don't know though one could say that
back to the question
one could say that having a laid back
attitude in jiu jitsu
then again on the street that'll be less
likely to have a laid back
yeah you just two in the street there's
exceptions everywhere i would think
but i would say you know if it's going
down it's going down
default aggressive get aggressive in the
street yeah telling
yeah once it goes once it happens once
the decision has been made
yeah get after it if it's go tegra if
it's not go time it's not good
as long as you can avoid as long as you
can but when you gotta go
go hard go